The joe rogan experience.
You don't blizzard in world of Warcraft,
I don't know the exact numbers,
but they had released a pet whereas it was like 25 actual dollars or something
like that and their servers wound up getting crashed and people lining up to buy
it just for like one little pet.
That's the power of those goods they've figured out how to do is make it so that
the more you play the game,
the better you get,
the better your life is,
the more successful you are,
the more powerful you are,
the better the experiences,
the more you have controller of the people in the game.
And that's like the really trippy thing.
It's like it's a time thing they like locked you in.
Like it's,
it's like it's a,
it's a show that you're totally hooked on and it never ends and it keeps getting
crazier everyday new people and they,
any,
any blizzard,
mark my words has created this mold that so many other people in the business
you're going to follow.
We got this,
uh,
this thing and the new gear.
So we have a calendar and it's like you play gears and it's like,
Oh hey,
you know,
don't trade in your game because in two weeks there's like ticker Tuesday or
triple XP Thursdays.
Right?
And then your friends are playing on that same day and you want to keep going.
Right.
And maybe there's like a psychology strict.
There were like,
you know,
you don't sell the game because you're thinking there might be something coming
up,
right.
We're dungeon masters and we're always like manipulating that experience online
to have new shit happen.
Yeah.
It's kind of crazy that it just keeps going though.
But I mean your average person have over their life to a world where he can
start gaining that control.
That's like the biggest problem.
Like when you're young,
it's figuring out what you want to do when you grow up.
Right?
Like thanks that.
Thankfully I was lucky and I saw games.
I was like,
boom,
that right.
But so I've talked to kids who are like,
I'm going to school and I don't know what I want to do.
It's like,
dude,
pick something and be surgical about it and decide that you're going to be the
best at that.
We'd put the problem is finding something.
For a lot of kids,
the real issue is finding something.
Then you got lucky.
I got lucky.
A lot of people did,
but it's like it's very difficult to find the thing that you're into.
You know?
You don't want to like say,
oh,
it's going to be this,
and then you're doing it and then halfway into it you're like this fucking blog.
And so it's difficult to find what that thing is.
It's like anchoring,
asking it a young,
especially the young age when you don't know,
you hardly know a lot about what's going on in the world around you.
But at the same time,
that opportunity now with the internet is greater than ever,
right?
Like you could shoot a viral video,
you could start a podcast,
you could do anything.
And if you start getting better and better at it,
you can build community,
right?
If that's what you want to do.
But what if you want to be a carpenter?
Or what if you want to be a painter?
You know there's,
there's so many for kids,
the hardest thing is finding the thing,
finding whatever the fuck it is.
Like,
you know,
most kids don't get enough exposure to interesting ideas between the schoolwork.
When you,
when you go to school,
when you think about what you've gotta do,
you've gotta get up at fucking seven o'clock in the morning.
You've got to leave,
catch a bus with a bunch of other Douche bags,
do a bunch of shit that sucks all day.
Listen to a bunch of people tell you never gonna make anything out of your life
unless you pay attention to them.
And they're like,
listen bitch,
you're teaching school.
I know you don't make any money.
Shut the fuck up.
Don't you love?
Oh,
life was so great when you're a kid.
Like no answered moments,
but it sucked.
So to find something that you truly love in the midst of all this,
like programming is what school is no more than programming.
It is education.
There is information that you're going to download it,
you're going to remember it,
but the reality of what it is is getting you program to get used to doing things
you don't want to do.
Listening to people that you don't want hear,
you're around people.
You don't want to be around the New Yorker.
There's a buzzer.
Why?
Why does it have to be a buzzer stupid?
Was it so important that we fucking leave at a certain time and get there at a
certain time?
You're turning me into a robot.
You know you're turning me into some worker asshole that just goes and does the
same God damn thing everyday and providing order for a certain mind that might
otherwise to either the default,
but again,
there's ways to educate.
Like my favorite hobbies,
if I'm out with friends and I was out in San Francisco with a buddy and he had a
date,
who is this a public school teacher at?
Anytime I find one of my polar sound like American memory by your drink and it
will just sit there and pick their brain for like an hour about.
My uncle's a public school teacher.
Does he have horror stories?
Oh of course.
Right.
Teachers in New Jersey.
Yeah.
Like you know like classes that are huge,
like kids who are young,
like super young hooking up and bathrooms and have to call child protective
services.
It's a,
it's a horror story out there.
Well,
you know,
they're all doing crazy shit now too because of the Internet.
You know,
you hear like 13 year olds are talking about,
you know,
making out one of the girls.
There was no girls making out with girls when I was 13 there.
Shit never took place.
They're all doing it.
You know,
13 year old girls.
Yeah.
That was the,
that I was 13 I knew a lot of 13 year olds,
dude.
And none of them were making out with each other.
Everybody would,
let's say they were going to do something and you never know quite what it was.
Right.
And there was this kind of like a Dell conspiracy to keep like pornography or
away from you and things like that.
You had to go in the woods and find porn.
We've talked about this a hundred times in the pod for meaning finding Portland
in the woods.
Yeah.
It's so funny.
Everyone's got the same story,
everybody.
It was incredible.
The dirty stuff.
We didn't bring this up to you and everyone has the same goddamn story and the
woods.
We find a magazine.
You shouldn't make an adult bookstore in the woods.
It would probably be the most successful.
Just don't even tell him any signs.
Here's like a Johnny Porno Ct.
It looks like Ron Jeremy and a thong going through with a giant sack of porn and
it's like Cherry Cherry.
Yeah,
it's not playboy.
It's the dirtiest shit you could find was the bad stuff we grew up with.
Oh,
your dog.
there we go.
It was always penthouse with a lot of water damage.
The girls look like that.
The SARLACC pit down there.
It was horrible.
Right,
and you're young,
impressionable mind.
It's like,
oh my God,
I'm supposed to think this is hot.
What is going on here?
Right.
It was terrifying,
but that's click of a button.
You can see two girls,
one cup.
Yeah.
We've talked about this before about how crazy it is,
how how close all this stuff is.
Like someone could send you a Twitter link and you click on it and just give to
be the most horrible thing.
My words,
if I ever have children,
like they were not going to get a cell phone until they're maybe 13 yeah.
But you know what the worst thing you want to have is an uninformed kid.
True,
true.
Talk to them and just let them be in the same flow as everybody else.
It's just to let them know what the fuck is going on while it's out.
As long as that basis there.
Right?
Yeah.
Look,
you know,
there's that old expression,
the kids are going to be all right.
You know,
and there they are.
They're going to be all right.
They're going to be fine.
She's like,
we're fine.
We're worried about them.
You know,
and I have little daughters and logically I can say this and of course,
you know paternally I just want to protect them and nerf the fucking world and
all that.
But I understand where that's coming from.
These kids going to be fine.
They're growing up with other human beings to some extent.
You want them to make their own mistakes.
Right?
I've known parents,
yes.
Pad The house of too much,
and it's like,
let him fall over once in a while.
Let them learn how balance.
Right.
Like,
well,
yeah,
but you know,
you gotta be careful.
You don't want them to,
I mean,
kids die,
you know,
they don't have a coal stove in the middle of the living room.
Right?
Yeah.
But I mean,
if you have hard floors,
you know,
like I have marble floors.
It's kind of tricky.
You know,
you've gotta you gotta watch them,
but,
but that's not the point.
The point is,
um,
you know what these are,
they're growing up with other people.
And I think p things always get better.
And even though it seems like Shit's worse,
he didn't know that.
It seems like Shit's worse as far as like the economy and all this craziness as
far as invasion of privacy and you know,
and uh,
the,
you know,
the access to information that we have and they're getting inundated with images
and videos and all this shit that we didn't see until we were well mature.
They're going to be fine.
They're just,
this is how they're growing up now.
This is just how it is and we're just the law,
the old people that are just like our parents,
like,
oh kids these days looking at,
um,
yeah,
it's the same video games.
It's the same thing.
It's just we're like,
we're like kids these days with their fucking ass to mouth porn.
You know,
they got asked to mouth porn on their fucking iPhone.
Well,
that's just what it is.
It's just this is the new world and the world constantly keeps getting more and
more complex world of ass to mouth.
It's,
the world is always getting more and more fucked up.
It's always getting more complicated,
more strange or bizarre.
Is it going to the Zombie apocalypse is the default.
It's always,
look,
I think as long as there's freedom of information,
the way we were expressing each other right now and communicating with each
other,
people are gonna be able to figure out things quicker.
You know,
and I think kids are going to be able to figure out this multifaceted,
fucked up chaotic world far quicker than some fucking doofus from 1963 and now
he takes some kid from 1963 you could talk him into anything they didn't know
shit.
You know today kids are going to be more savvy,
more aware,
more installation.
Ask anybody anything anymore.
Yeah,
fuck it up.
You can find it in the act was complaining about this actually he was a,
there was a Steve Wasniak,
one of the creators of apple was doing an interview where he cited saying,
back in my day,
you know,
you had a,
if you will add a question,
you had to find a smart person and ask them,
well that's dumb.
Why would I,
why are you complaining about that?
There's not that many fucking smart people,
but I've got to seek out one dude.
That's retarded.
I have to go and talk to the professor.
That's why they're so God damn arrogant about their information.
Think about the Mayans,
right?
What they used to control them by the,
you know,
the,
all the quote priests,
you know,
figure it out.
Science.
I figure it out.
You know,
how the,
uh,
you know,
the lunar cycles and how everything would turn out and think.
Everyone was like,
wow,
how do they know this?
It must be magic.
Or like we're controlling this through knowledge,
right?
Yeah.
Well there's,
yeah,
but now the Egyptians to,
before the library of Alexandria burned down,
they had,
I mean that was the idea as well.
They kept all the knowledge,
they had all this information,
but all sorts of different things that the lay person was unaware of so
everybody can get it.
Google,
bitch.
Damn you.
We used to have to seek out a Tim Sweeney or John Carmax,
right.
And hang on to the right of up to the top.
That's true.
Now there's just fucking a computer connection to the Internet and all your
questions answered.
But it's not always true,
dude.
Not,
oh,
that's a thing.
But it's getting there.
It released sitting closer and closer.
It's getting to the point.
There's a lot of disinformation,
but there's also a lot of information.
There's a lot of good information and I think that's because I think it
developed it just like we need to be able to discern between bullshit and
reality in the real world.
You need to be able to discern between bullshit and reality online and people
will sort it all out and figure it out.
You know,
if you know,
there's a lot of people that have it,
there's a lot of urban myths about all sorts of different things.
You know,
if you drink a coke and take,
you know,
fucking this with it,
you'll die.
You know the,
I mean,
how many different stories,
if we ever heard when they need just go online approx growing up.
Yes,
that's right.
That's what it was.
It was Mikey from the life cereal commercial dye to stomach explodes,
right where there was their religion about the girl that stuck a hot dog in her
pussy and then had to go to the hospital.
You never heard that one?
Didn't hear that one.
That was the other one there.
Right.
And the maggots were starting coming out of your ass.
And then there's the one about the lobster that right.
You heard that one right?
What was that one?
That girl apparently took him off to the lab staff.
Lobster,
put it in here and then like lit a match to it and make its tail flip around and
turns up the lobster had like,
like planted a bunch of eggs in her and then three weeks later she died and all
that.
Yeah,
I could certainly see that some disgusting girl was shit breath telling me that
story.
It really seems like life is going towards like the having a matrix where you
live in a bubble in your whole life is like,
oh,
she took this labs fast.
He's fucking in that Plessy.
Right.
And it was all fucking loved.
It just traps his eggs in a snatch.
It was a lobster fest to fucking lapse as a crime.
I have a pussy.
What a Hoe
[inaudible].